la nouvelle hausse du taux de
financement un jour c'est certainement
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
propriétaires immobiliers du Canada qui
vont voir leur mensualité hypothécaire
variable augmentée on va discuter tout
ça avec Simon Lupien et les
co-fondateurs pour télépather chez
appointhe hypothèque bonsoir Monsieur
Lupien est-ce que cette huitième hall du
taux directeur vous croyez va faire en
sorte que il y a de moins en moins de
gens qui frappent à votre porte ou en
détresse plutôt vont chercher vos
conseils en fait on pense que ça va être
la hausse qui va juste confirmer que
faut prendre une pause peut-être si on
est un acheteur et plusieurs personnes
sont en la recherche depuis quand même
plusieurs mois puis se disent bah on va
attendre un petit peu cette hausse et là
maintenant mais ça vient confirmer que
donc on va attendre on va attendre un
peu qu'on va attendre pour lorsque les
taux d'intérêt vont descendre un peu
plus tard et que le marché peut être ce
sera calmé davantage entre temps ça
reste à voir mais on montrait des
chiffres tout à l'heure qu'on peut
revoir d'ailleurs une simulation là pour
un emprunt de 400 000 dollars amorti sur
25 ans ce que ça peut représenter la
hausse d'aujourd'hui
une soixantaine de dollars par mois à
peu près 700 dollars en une année mais
pour la hausse d'un quart de pointe
pourcentage aujourd'hui si on cumule
depuis le mois de mars 2022 toutes les
hausses presque 900 dollars par mois
10000 dollars par année est-ce qu'il y a
encore des gens qui sont capables de se
payer ça les gens vous disent quoi quand
il voit ses chiffres-là en fait qui se
disent que c'est des choses qu'on peut
pas prévoir de toute façon il y a
beaucoup de monde qui se disent ben on
va le payer on le sait que c'est une
situation qui est temporaire on l'entend
énormément il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont qui sont quand même conscients
qu'on est dans une situation
particulière et puis en ont conscience
que normalement ça va pas rester de
cette manière là encore pour plusieurs
années donc il y a quand même cette
phénomène de compréhension de de ce
moment unique dans lequel nous vivons il
y a beaucoup d'emprunteurs qui en ont
conscience néanmoins mais ça commence ça
commence quand même à chauffer ça
commence quand même avoir de
l'inquiétude aussi par rapport à ça
c'est quoi le plafond au niveau des taux
d'intérêt on le sait pas ce que c'est
aujourd'hui peut-être est-ce que ça
jusqu'à quel point ça freine l'accès au
marché des gens qui étaient en démarche
avec vous et qui doivent carrément se
retirer de ce processus là mais il faut
attendre que par rapport par exemple à
l'année dernière donc sans recul 11 mois
auparavant donc avant la hausse la
première hausse de mars 2022 4.25 - cher
donc forcément ben on peut parler comme
un ménage qui gagne 120 000 dollars par
année pourrait aujourd'hui qualifier
pour une propriété aux alentours de
150000 dollars plus cher donc
naturellement ça fait en sorte que ça
vient freiner le niveau de possibilité
en sachant que les propriétés n'ont pas
nécessairement descendus de manière
assez importante donc forcément ça fait
en sorte que beaucoup de gens doivent
réviser leur plan est-ce qu'on décide
d'aller changer de quartier changer de
ville de s'éloigner ou bien on prend une
pause et on reste en logement encore un
petit peu plus longtemps est-ce
les institutions financières bon c'est
presque automatique là on nous a annoncé
des jeunes du taux préférentiels pour
demain est-ce que il y a avantages à
magasiner encore est-ce que le marché
est toujours aussi concurrentiel dans un
marché ou les taux augmentent de manière
générale en fait plus que jamais c'est
important de prendre une pause avant de
soit renouveler son hypothèque ou bien
d'acheter une propriété quand je parle
de prendre une pause c'est de faire un
bilan de sa situation de faire un bilan
de ses actifs de ces passifs de ses
projets et à partir de là d'avoir
vraiment un plan de match qui va être
personnalisé à savoir comment je fais
pour gérer ma hausse de paiement est-ce
que je suis en mesure de pouvoir
justement arriver avec un paiement de
500 600 700 dollars de plus comment on
peut faire parce que des trucs et des
stratégies qu'on peut utiliser pour
atténuer ses augmentations de paiement
là et c'est ce qu'un courtier protocole
peut faire par exemple il y a des
économistes qui nous disent qu'avec
cette hausse là la proportion
d'emprunteur à taux variable qui
atteignent leur taux limite va augmenter
et on craint qu'il y a des gens qui
soient plus capables de payer est-ce
qu'on observe déjà ça des vagues de
remise volontaires des ventes forcées
par les propriét qui ont pu les moyens
en fait présentement les chiffres que
nous avons sont on voit en fait que très
très peu de repas volontaires en fait
dans l'ensemble du Canada il y a très
très peu en fait de repart qui se font
dans les derniers mois est-ce que les
gens présentement vont cesser
dramatiquement de rembourser leur prêt
hypothécaire mon opinion c'est que je ne
pense pas qu'on va voir ça parce que
justement on ne voit pas les derniers
nécessairement de propriété avec de
liquider négatives on voit très peu de
propriété dans le Grand Montréal dans le
Québec au complet des propriétés à
équité négatives donc les gens savent
que leur bien immobilier vaut quand même
plus cher que la valeur de leur prêt
hypothécaire donc on voit pas le même
phénomène qu'on a déjà observé lors de
la dernière crise économique aux
Etats-Unis en 2007 2008 on ne voit pas
ça présentement donc beaucoup de gens
vont rester sur leur propriété en
sachant que le remède de cheval un jour
il va passer et un moment donné on va
pouvoir arriver avec des taux d'intérêt
qui monte un peu plus normal je vous
pose la question que tout le monde se
pose avant de vous laisser aller
dans le contexte actuel est-ce qu'on
choisit tout fixe taux variable c'est
quoi la meilleure stratégie encore une
fois c'est la question qu'on nous pose à
tous les jours chaque jour il y a pas de
bonnes réponses la bonne réponse c'est
que ça dépend ça dépend en fait de la
situation si on a quelqu'un qui veut
vendre sa propriété son de quelqu'un qui
a des projets de Rachine propriété ou
que il peut arriver n'importe quoi parce
que la vie est variable donc forcément
un taux variable mais ça va tuer avec
notre vie on sait que quelqu'un qui
prend un tour variable aujourd'hui
risque d'avoir des paiements plus élevés
pendant les deux prochaines années
versez quelqu'un qui va prendre un taux
fixe donc plusieurs personnes vont
prendre le taux fixe temporairement le
temps que ça se calme et après ça va
venir vers une normalité et peut-être
reprendre notre variable plus tard pour
ne pas se priver effectivement des taux
d'intérêt qui pourraient descendre à la
fin de l'année est-ce que c'est ce que
vous conseillez en ce moment aux gens
qui vous consultent en fait on aime bien
comprendre les besoins des clients on
aime bien comprendre c'est quoi leur
valeur on aime bien comprendre qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent faire à partir de là si
les gens une tolérance au risque
importante si les gens comprennent que
pendant les deux prochaines années ça va
être inconfortable mais que nous sommes
probablement au sommet à ce moment
quelqu'un qui invariable va vraiment
voir ses paiements diminué dans les
prochaines années très claire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été l'homme s'il vous
plaît
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]